foreign
let's go out to Flint Michigan and talk
to Nicole what's up Nicole
hi Hi
how are we doing how's it going
party ahead rocking on to the Breaking
Dawn what's up everybody in here happy
Friday that's why not right absolutely
yep so what's up
um Okay so
I've had this question for as long as
I've been married which has been eight
years
and I just I cannot I cannot seem to
figure it out and it's just going around
in a circle and it needs to get better
at this point
um so my question is how can I better
serve my husband's love language which
is acts of service I think because it
it's really communication is the the
thing and I think communication falls
into acts of service
um and it's he tells me that that's what
he needs more of is communication
um and why do you think communication
why do you think communication means
acts of service how do you get there
um I think because when he says
communication
it's like he wants me to work with him
or as a team like
um
just
tell him how I like what I am planning
to do or
um I don't know just be on the same page
with things help him with me okay the
way you're and I'm smiling with you
right so you and I are hanging out right
we're not I'm not laughing at you the
way you're describing this is though
it's like he wants me to spray paint my
face blue and red and then sing Adele
songs in Spanish like you're describing
things that are so crazy but the way
you're saying it is like like what
you're actually saying is he wants me to
like tell him what's on my mind and
involve him in plans like super super
rational things he's asking for here so
I don't know it's just hard to explain
like when it sounds like okay go with me
here and I've got two phds that's how
I'm able to figure this out
um what if you just uh
told him what you were thinking and
invited him along on the plans that you
had for that like of the things he's
asking for
no it's like I am like the the person
that handles our daily schedules and I
feel like I do a good job of telling
them what's going on and keeping him in
the loop it's like the little things
that come up
um that he just finds
that are becoming problems and I don't
feel like they're a problem or give me
an example like
for instance
um just recently uh and they're usually
like little things it's like um
we have water bottles for the kids and
um we keep losing them and and we're
spending money on more water bottles and
he's like I think we should get some
more water bottles and I'm like yeah we
should and in my head I'm thinking like
yeah I want to see if I can find them
first or
um I'll just have to buy some new ones I
guess if we can't find them but I'm not
speaking that out loud I'm not
telling him like what my plans are in my
head so he thinks that he's just
speaking out these problems and I'm not
telling him what I'm planning to do and
he's getting frustrated he's a hundred
percent right
so what like why why wouldn't you just
tell him like hey there's a bigger issue
here the kids keep losing water bottles
and I don't feel comfortable continuing
to support their habit of not keeping up
with their things
and so if the kids keep losing their
water bottle they're making choices to
not have water bottles like what
prohibits you is it not safe to say that
or are you uncomfortable saying that
because I I think his complaint is is
dead on I keep saying hey we need to
grab we're out of water bottles I can
actually even see a moment where he
thinks he's helping hey all the water
bottles are gone when you go to the
store next time can you grab a couple
and then you start a story in your head
an explanation and a narrative but you
don't share it and then you come back
and there's no water bottles and he
thinks my wife just ignores me she
didn't even say no she just said okay
and then nothing I see what I'm saying I
get what
what am I missing here
yeah it's it's like I feel like I have
to be in control of everything and that
I can handle it that I'll get to it that
I'll work on it in my time or and I am
not saying it out loud I'm just thinking
that I can handle it
but why are those Mutual why are those
mutually exclusive
like you can handle it clearly I mean
you can I mean you're you're smart and
accomplished you can do what you need to
do but why can't you also say it out
loud
I don't know I'm just
follows her
um same thing with like the kids
outgrown some clothes and they need some
new jeans and he mentions it and I'm
like okay yeah let me see first if we do
have enough pants before I go buy more
but I don't say it out loud I'm just
thinking like okay okay but you haven't
answered my question why
why am I doing that why are you not
saying that here here's the thing it
could be that every time you say
something he swears at you all right he
shoves you to the ground
and you have learned you better keep
your thoughts and opinions to yourself
because he's not safe that could be a
case
or it could be he's just the sweetest
guy on planet Earth and he's just like
trying to help out by pointing things
like by saying oh yeah hey I saw Timmy
the other day and his pants don't fit
we're gonna need to grab him some new
ones and because of the way you have
divided up your household he takes care
of some things you take care of other
things and those other things happen to
be kids clothes and
you just don't tell him
is is it safe for you to tell him things
um I feel like
the the way that he talks about things
he'll talk
um loudly or
not seem like easy to have a
conversation with some of the time okay
or depending on what the situation is
like the different issues so he'll get
loud and I'll he tells me that I get
defensive when he brings things up and
and I feel like he doesn't see that I am
working on something and
um and then if I say like oh yeah I've
done that or I help out here too and and
then he thinks that I'm just being
defensive and that he doesn't see that I
I am doing things and I I don't know
when he gets like loud in conversations
and feels like it's like I'm getting in
trouble for something then I either shut
down or
um just am not as easy to talk to
and you are right 100 on for that
the new language is
not just shutting down and disappearing
the new language is when he starts
yelling
you put up both hands until he stops for
a second and you say I am choosing to
not be in a conversation with somebody
that's treating me like I'm seven I'm
not your daughter
I'm choosing to not be in a conversation
with you if you're going to yell and
raise your voice
so I'm gonna take a break for 30 minutes
and if you want to re-engage this
conversation at a normal talking level
I'd love to do that
and then you walk away
okay is that safe to do
um I have like
why are you yelling right now no it's
not that's not helpful because here's
what here's why that's not helpful
because he is gonna feel that as an
attack because you are talking about his
behavior
when you put both of your hands up and
say I'm choosing to disengage the whole
conversations about you
here's what I'm gonna do
in resp because I get to choose my
thoughts and my actions
you're raising your voice cool knock
your lights out I am not engaging in
that conversation has nothing to do with
yelling at him about him yelling or
pointing out what he's doing wrong
there's some great uh literature that
suggests even it was it was done with
some with political affiliation
um if someone has a political belief and
you show them empirically here is the
data that proves without a shadow of
doubt you are wrong
it actually
entrenches their view deeper
so if if someone was like all the
conservatives believe this that the Blue
Sky theory is liberal propaganda the sky
is green
and you literally got like a
spectrometer and you laid it out and
you're like no we just here look here's
NASA has done all this research the sky
is actually blue
somebody who's entrenched in that belief
because you're telling them they're
wrong they're thinking about something
wrong they're doing the wrong thing they
actually walk away thinking this guy is
greener than it was before
and so we're not gonna We're Not Gonna
lob grenades why are you doing this why
are you raising your voice because now
we're attacking even if you're right
he can't hear it because he's switched
parts of his brain
and so all I'm going to do is control
what I can control I'm gonna control me
and if it's as simple as
hey let's have these conversations
here's what me and my wife do I can just
let me just tell you this way we have a
meeting once a week that talks about
calendar talks about what the week's
going to look like and this is where my
wife just keeps a note card with her I
keep a note card with me and we write
things down to ourselves
uh Hank needs new clothes Josephine's
gonna have a thing for YMCA whatever and
we got this and we've got a thing coming
up and I'm gonna be on I took another
speaking gig I'm gonna be on the road
and so that when we get together and
talk about these things it's very
impassioned it's just math I mean it's
it's just we're just doing it like
having a business meeting basically
um turns out that meeting is like
foreplay right it's it's connection and
all these other things but it's just
like hey we need to do this it's gonna
cost 35 bucks for you to do this it
keeps it from being
hey you where were you today you were
late getting home and suddenly he goes
on the defensive and looks at you and
goes hey you got those new pants for
Timmy yet and you're like well I'm
thinking I'm working on it I just
haven't checked and now we're in a whole
you see what I'm saying now we're in a
whole fight
yeah now we're down a whole road that
we'd never had to get down right so it's
keeping those things both of y'all
agreeing to hey can we start having
these conversations at a scheduled time
every week write them down so that we
remember them and that way I can keep on
top of all these things and you can
begin to practice saying those stories
in your head out loud
is that something you can work on
yeah and it's been top of mind since we
kind of had this talk like a week ago
and he's we're trying to figure out like
like in general like what do you need
from me yeah and he says I need
communication I need more of it if I if
you think that you're doing it do more
of it and I it it's just like it I make
up this excuse like it's not it doesn't
sound that easy to do because it's not
like a physical act like to me like if
my love language is like
um
so what is it spent quality time like
that's a physical act so that you can
actually do and see and so this one this
one is absolutely I think it's
absolutely a physical act
I think I think it is very much a
physical act I I think
for some reason and you and I could
probably spend like two hours talking
together I think there is
whether it was something you've been
dealing with since you're a kid whether
it's something you have adopted to to
stay safe in your current relationship
or you had some boyfriend in college who
knows but for some reason you don't feel
safe your body doesn't feel safe
communicating
telling out loud hey here's what I
actually think about this or I hear you
say we need some more dental floss
pretty sure we have some in the basement
give me a minute I'm gonna go there and
check on it instead of just saying that
sentence you just say nothing
and that's speaking those things out
loud is communication that is a physical
act
and so here's what I want you to do I
want you to start practice saying it and
I want you to tell your husband it feels
weird I'm gonna try over communicating
when I have these thoughts in my head
I'm going to say them out loud and that
means sometimes you're going to say them
the wrong way
you're going to say them a little bit
sharper
you might say them in a way that hurts
his feelings and you need to tell him
while I'm practicing learning how to
over communicate
you have to promise that you will not
raise your voice
you have to promise that if I say
something the wrong way that comes
across as an attack to you that you will
take a big deep breath and exhale
and you won't come after me on it and
you will say thank you for communicating
and that way you're creating safe
boundaries while you practice this thing
it's the reason
um most NBA teams don't let camera crews
in during practice they're practicing
plays they're going to fall down they're
going to miss shots they're gonna miss
dunks it's not the game
so you've got to create boundaries to
practice this because this is new for
you and you're going to feel awkward and
you're going to feel weird but I want
you to practice just saying things out
loud more and more get out of your own
head
okay it is an action it is a physical
step and don't
um when he says I need more
communication and if you think you're
over communicating do it five times x
I don't want you to hear that and go oh
he must mean acts of service take him at
his word
and then if you're over communicating
and he starts to say well actually I
just want you to help me with okay well
now you're changing the tune but as for
right now
I think what's not working out in your
communication patterns is he's being
very direct with you saying his needs
out loud and you're hearing those needs
and you don't want to do what that need
is you want to do something else
and so my challenge to you is do what
you can to meet that need because I
don't think it's unreasonable
and it's not unreasonable for you to not
be in a conversation with somebody who's
going to raise their voice at you
it is not unreasonable for you to not
want to be romantic with somebody who
acts like your dad
and that you're his kid
it's not unreasonable for you to feel
unsafe if every time you push back a
little bit on something he yells and
gets mad or hits something or bangs on
something
so we're gonna step back together and
we're not gonna do this across the table
at each other we're going to be on the
same side here and say okay here's the
problem is communication how are we
going to tackle this thing I'm going to
over communicate you're going to treat
me safely and now we're heading off into
a brand new relationship